We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21centry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Keeping money in a savings account where there is interest is logical. Let's pretend you've never been to a bank before.
我们得到加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命的一部分。请访问 21centry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。把钱存在有利息的储蓄账户里是合乎逻辑的。我们假设你以前从未去过银行。
Douglas McGregor is going to be our guide. You walk through the door, you see the red carpeting, you see someone in a suit there, maybe greeting you, you see some ferns, you know, a nice row of professional looking people in suits behind the counter. You don't really see what it is they offer. Chances are if you walk into the bank, you look around, you're not gonna see a lot of services
道格拉斯·麦格雷戈将成为我们的向导。你走进大门，看到红色的地毯，看到柜台后面可能有人在向你打招呼，看到一些蕨类植物，你知道，柜台后面有一排穿着西装、看起来很专业的专业人士。你其实看不出他们提供的是什么。如果你走进银行，环顾四周，你很可能看不到很多服务
or prices. You have to kind of know what you want going in there. Or you have to talk with someone to help you figure it out. If you think about it almost like it's like, if you went to a restaurant and there's no menu on the door and you walk inside and like instead of giving you a menu, they ask, what do you want? And you go Italian and then you have a conversation
或价格。你必须大致知道自己进去想要什么。或者你必须与某人交谈以帮助你弄清楚。如果你仔细想想，这有点像，如果你去一家餐厅，门上没有菜单，你走进去，他们不是给你一份菜单，而是问，你想要什么？然后你说意大利菜，接着你们进行了一次对话
about what they could provide and the 17 different sauces they could offer and all the different shapes of pasta. A reasonable person might think, like it'd be kind of nice to have a menu. Doug McGregor is a journalist. My name is Douglas McGregor. I'm a fellow at the New America Foundation and I'm the Editor-in-Chief of Pop Up Magazine.
关于他们能提供什么以及他们能提供的 17 种不同的酱汁和所有不同形状的意大利面。一个理智的人可能会觉得，有个菜单其实挺好的。道格·麦格雷戈是一名记者。我的名字叫道格拉斯·麦格雷戈。我是新美国基金会的研究员，也是《弹窗杂志》的总编辑。
And a couple of years ago, he wrote a story about Czechasers and Payday Lenders, which McGregor is quick to point out these are different services. Check cashing is when you have a check, it's made out to you. You go in with a check, you leave with cash. Minus a 3% fee or so, and payday lending is when you don't have any money. So you write the payday lender a check.
几年前，他写了一篇关于支票兑现商和发薪日贷款机构的故事，麦格雷戈很快指出这些是不同的服务。支票兑现是指你有一张支票，上面写着你的名字。你带着支票进去，拿着现金离开。扣除大约 3% 的费用，而发薪日贷款是指你没有任何钱。所以你给发薪日贷款机构开了一张支票。
For $350 and you get $300 and they cashed in two weeks. Those are the much more problematic transactions if you happen to think charging 400% interest is bad for the working poor, but McRae found that for better or worse. You know, I think it's mostly for worse. These places are here to stay. What made surprise you though, if you have the same visceral reaction that I used to have to them?
金额为 350 美元，你得到 300 美元，他们在两周内兑现。如果你碰巧认为收取 400% 的利息对工薪阶层穷人有害，这些交易会更有问题，但麦克雷发现，不管好坏。你知道，我认为主要还是坏的。这些地方将长期存在。不过，如果你对它们有和我过去一样的本能反应，可能会让你感到惊讶的是？
If it's a person who's used to going to banks, they're gonna think they're a little bit grimy. Is that these check cashing stores, even with their problems? The fees are too high, I can't say that enough. You know, the fees are at most of them are too high. May teach banks something about using design to better serve a wider range of customers. The absence of the bank-like trappings, plush carpeting, ferns, big desks, suits, they're
如果是一个习惯去银行的人，他们会觉得这些地方有点肮脏。这些支票兑现店，即使它们存在问题？手续费太高了，我怎么强调都不为过。你知道，大多数地方的手续费都太高了。可能会教给银行一些东西，即如何通过设计更好地服务更广泛的客户。缺少类似银行的陈设，毛绒地毯、蕨类植物、大办公桌、西装，它们
missing for a reason. When Doug McGray went on a tour of a branch with Tom Nicks, who at the time was the owner of the largest chain of check cashing stores in Southern California, Nicks pointed out the design choices he made. He pointed out the linoleum floor, and he said, you know, if you go into a bank, you're going to see a carpeted floor and say a guy is coming off of his construction shift, he's in his work boots, if he walks across the carpeted floor, say a guy is coming off of his construction shift He's in his work boots. He walks across the carpeted floor He's gonna feel like a jerk. I don't know if he's right or wrong, but it was an interesting point And it was a conscious choice. You know, they would they would not put down carpeting Nick's also worked really hard to make his places seem just like retail
消失是有原因的。当道格·麦格雷戈与当时南加州最大的支票兑现连锁店老板汤姆·尼克斯一起参观一家分行时，尼克斯指出了他所做的设计选择。他指着油毛毡地板说，你知道，如果你走进一家银行，你会看到铺着地毯的地板，比如说一个刚下建筑班次的工人在穿著工作靴，如果他踩着铺了地毯的地板走过去，比如说一个刚下建筑班次的工人他穿着工作靴。他踩着铺了地毯的地板走过去，他会觉得自己像个白痴。我不知道他是对是错，但这确实是一个有趣的观点，而且这是一个有意识的选择。你知道，他们不会铺地毯，尼克斯也非常努力地让他的地方看起来就像零售店一样
It reminds me a lot of a corner store only instead of selling chips and soda and stuff like that It's financial services and everyone patronizes and is welcome of a corner store, only instead of selling chips and soda and stuff like that, it's financial services. And everyone patronizes and is welcome at a corner store, rich and poor, and you know what, everything costs. One of the most important things, maybe the most important thing, at this chain of checkaches,
这让我想起了一个街角小店，只不过它卖的不是薯片、苏打水之类东西，而是金融服务，每个人都光顾街角小店并且受到欢迎，富人和穷人都是如此，而且你知道吗，每样东西都有价格。在这家支票兑现连锁店中，最重要的事情之一，也许是最重要的事情，
and you'll see this at a lot of them, there was a big list of prices on the wall, and it was all really straightforward. And the prices were, for the most part, the prices were too high. But you weren't going to wonder what something was going to cost. You weren't going to wonder what they could do for you. And when I talk to people who chose to go to check cashers, a lot of them had had a bank at one point. They signed up for some free checking account, but then all of a sudden they had these fees and they would like read these statements that were
你会在很多这样的地方看到，墙上有一张很大的价格表，而且非常直观。在大多数情况下，价格确实太高了。但你不会去猜某样东西要花多少钱。你不会去猜他们能为你做些什么。当我与选择去支票兑现店的人交谈时，他们中的很多人以前都有过银行账户。他们注册了一些免费支票账户，但突然之间他们有了这些费用，他们会阅读这些
pages long and they couldn't figure out where they were getting charged, what they were getting charged. Plus, you aren't paralyzed by the vast number of options available to you. If you go to your bank, chances are, you know, they'll have like five different savings accounts. They'll have five different checking accounts. They'll have all these investment accounts. They'll have college savings accounts. You know, it's a research project. It's hard to figure out which one is right for you. And I for one always seem to leave with the feeling that I picked the wrong one. The Czech cashers and payday lenders they'll have a bunch of different services, but there will only be one of each.
长达好几页的对账单，却弄不清他们被收了什么费，因什么被收费。另外，你不会被大量的可用选项弄得眼花缭乱。如果你去你的银行，很有可能，你知道，他们会有大约五种不同的储蓄账户。他们会有五种不同的支票账户。他们会有所有这些投资账户。他们会有大学储蓄账户。你知道，这是一个研究项目。很难弄清楚哪一个适合你。而我个人似乎总是带着选错了的感觉离开。支票兑现商和发薪日贷款机构会有很多不同的服务，但每种服务都只有一种。
So you can cash your checks and it costs this much. You can wire money to your family in another country and it costs this much. It's all designed to be really simple. Let's pretend you've never been to a bank before. I think some banks are realizing that their cookie cutter, suburban branch, you know, they can't drop it down and have it work everywhere. You know, it's one thing. If you open to bank account with your parents when you were eight years old and you've been going there forever and all the weirdness of a bank, the no prices and the pamphlets and the ferns, like all
所以你可以兑现支票，费用是这么多。你可以把钱汇给在另一个国家的家人，费用是这么多。这一切都旨在非常简单。我们假设你以前从未去过银行。我想一些银行开始意识到他们千篇一律的郊区网点，你知道，它们不能随便落地生根并在任何地方都发挥作用。你知道，这是一回事。如果你在八岁时和父母一起开了一个银行账户，而且你一直去那里，银行所有的奇怪之处，没有价格、小册子和蕨类植物，就像所有
the stuff that's kind of strange about a bank when you think about it. It's just normal because that's what a bank is. Well, if you don't know what a bank is, if it's not normal, then maybe it's weird. 99% Invisible was produced by me Roman Mars with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW, the American Institute of Architects, San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture and Design. To find out more, go to 99%invisible.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那些当你仔细想想觉得很奇怪的事情，都变得很正常了，因为这就是银行本来的样子。好吧，如果你不知道什么是银行，如果它不正常，那么也许它很奇怪。《99%隐形》由我罗曼·马尔斯制作，并得到了用创意创造改变的 Lunar 的支持。这是 KALW、美国建筑师学会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心的合作项目。欲了解更多信息，请访问 99%invisible.org。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。